well Dana Kennedy is an American
journalist based in France who's written
about burglaries involving gas on the
Riviera she joins us from Paris via
Skype good evening to you how prevalent
are crimes like this which involve
gassing well I first found out about it
five years ago so it's pretty hard for
me to read these accounts and UK papers
in which local officials are saying
they're skeptical because it was in the
nice might add five years ago I didn't
go looking for this story there was an
article almost like a public service
announcement warning people in
campervans who camp along the public
campgrounds along the French interstate
highways to be careful because Eastern
European criminal gangs were sneaking up
at the camper vans at night opening the
air-conditioning vents and gassing them
the key thing is you may they want you
to be there they want you to be in the
camper van they want you to be in the
villa because what they want our laptops
cameras jewelry if you're not in the
bill they're not looking for Picasso's
they're looking for stuff that you bring
there when you're rich well you're
guessing someone in a camper vans one
thing that's quite a confined space
we're talking about a villa presuming it
is a fairly large villa then that's much
more difficult as we're hearing experts
say they're trying to pump that full of
anesthetic gases a lot harder I to a
quite a few security experts on the
French Riviera for this and they said it
wasn't really that difficult they said
it's usually air conditioning vent in
some cases they sneak in and they put it
in the master bedroom I have a friend
who is a high-end estate agent in can
she woke up with a headache one day and
at first thought was everything was okay
then saw that her nightstand inches from
her her head had been cleaned out her
closets were cleaned out jewelry was
taken the bags were taken and the most
incredible thing i have to tell you is
that she had high-end purses the real
deal designer purses and knock offs she
had real jewelry and costume jewelry and
the thieves only took the real jewelry
and the real bags and in fact she had a
Balenciaga that she thought was the real
thing they didn't take it she later had
to test it it was a knockoff so these
thieves know what they're doing and in
fact the security guy said that the
ether they used he who he use the word
either in fact you can get it at auto
parts stores
he didn't really want to tell me that
because I said why is this being used in
America you know I mean I'm American so
I'm used to I come from New York I'm
thinking why isn't it being done there
he said I hope they don't find out about
that well this takes a bit of planning
doesn't it i mean you're saying you've
had people you know people who've had
these kind of crimes committed what kind
of things are lonely signs perhaps that
you are being staked out for such a
robbery when I first moved the south of
France 10 years ago be coming from New
York I was absolutely shocked to find
out how incredibly common even regular
home invasions are home burglaries
pickpocketing robbery all the time you
know the problem with places like
marbella in Spain and nice france and
san Tropez is the local officials have a
huge investment in not really letting
the truth be known about how bad crime
is there that's really what what's
happening here it's not so much that it
hasn't gone on for many years it truly
is the home of dirty rotten scandals it
truly is a sunny place for shady people
but the local papers a local officials
I'm not being paranoid I live there I
know the place I've experienced it I
know people who are crime victims they
don't want to tell you and people want
to believe the myth especially the south
of France not so much pain that the
south and France is like untouchable
extraordinary get to space to you thank
you